Hello Freak bitches,
right?
It's very different than a regular movie.
What did he start doing these cereal?
I mean,
I think of like game of
Thrones is a serial movie,
right?
There's a hundred parts to this movie,
but it's a big giant ass movie.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's so much better than a
regular television show in
terms of like it's special
effects and the grandness of it all.
If they can figure out how
to film something like that,
but let you participate in it.
I mean,
I'll let you strap on to some three d
treadmill type thing and move around in
this fucking weird world and follow
these people on their journeys.
Be Right there when the ORC
slaughter the people like God,
like the blood splatter in front of you
and you're watching them get chopped up
and then you're going to go over
the mountain to where the castle is.
You have to actually
walk over the mountain,
but as you walk over the mountain,
horses ride beside you,
you get to see them.
I mean,
we're real close to something like that.
I feel like that's only a few years away.
Avatar world coming out soon.
Like in Disney at Disney.
Disney world.
Oh,
what are I going to do?
How's that going to work?
One of the,
they've been showing
some things like this is,
I think this is just a
imagineering whoa idea,
but this like you're gonna be able to
take a boat ride through the middle of the
Navi forest.
Oh,
okay.
Well that sounds like it's a small world.
It's going to be a lower step,
but they're going to have some VR stuff
you're gonna be able to float through
and go on the,
wow.
Here's how they are looking
to Disney world right now.
Oh Wow.
So they're,
they're building it right now,
but you're obviously not
to be able to walk on that.
When is this going to take place?
I think it opens this later this year.
Disneyland does next years.
But what you're saying,
what if they just took the extension of
that and just instead of like making the
avatar movie,
they just went,
look,
Avatar five is avatar world and
if you want to come live it out,
you've got to come to Disney world and
pay 50 bucks or 100 bucks or 150 bucks,
300 bucks,
something crazy to do it.
Now you're talking.
That would be all,
this is what you do.
You construct that world.
And then once you're in that world,
then you put on the VR goggles and it
turns everything into fluorescent neon
Greens and Blues and
like the Avatar world.
You could see everything and then you
actually watched the movie play out in
there.
Ooh,
that'd be a nerd gas me.
I feel like
closer to something like that then.
Well we are everyone being able
to do with this probably span.
Well the thing about that though is it's
going to require so much resources and
land and money and that doesn't change,
right?
But we have these notions of fairness
play out in different ways as we're
adults,
but different political
groups and different tribes
favor these other notions of
fairness more than some others.
So take for example,
the issue of pro life versus pro choice.
Right.
Okay.
So you have,
let's just,
here's the question.
Are Liberals prolife or
are liberals pro choice,
they're more pro choice
on the issue of abortion.
Yes.
So on abortion it's about freedom,
right?
Okay.
Uh,
well,
it's very much about women's rights,
women's freedom.
It's a big,
uh,
it's not,
it's not even thought of it
like as a human freedom because,
uh,
it's,
it's about the woman,
not about the child.
That's right.
So it's about the woman's freedom,
right?
So they've hooked up to
that idea of freedom,
right?
Yes.
And then,
you know,
conservatives are pro life.
This is about caring and protecting
from harm and all that sort of stuff.
Okay.
Unless you're talking about war,
unless you're talking about war.
And that's exactly the point is,
is that,
you know,
are all humans hypocrites or is it that
we selectively use these same intuitions
that we all have for different causes?
So if you look at,
for example,
gun control are liberals
pro choice or pro life,
they're definitely prolife.
Aha.
So what you see is that on abortion
they're pro choice and on gun control
they're pro life.
But then when it comes the other way,
exactly.
Publicans are pro choice
when it comes to guns.
So we all have the same intuitions,
but we use them in different ways
to justify our political arguments.
Well,
what's interesting too is that there's
two positions that are taking place in
the American psyche,
at least,
that were almost reluctantly agreeing
to and is that the Republicans are,
or the Conservatives are more realistic,
more hardcore,
ready to kick ass ready
to fight for what's right.
Whereas liberals are bunch of whiny
crybabies looking to give away their money
and they creating welfare babies.
Well,
that certainly just if it wasn't for,
if it wasn't for the conservatives,
these fucking people would be
speaking German and living in Vietnam.
Right.
Well,
all tribes,
the nature of tribes,
you tell something that makes your
tribe look like the good guys,
right?
That the sport,
is it ever going to be clean?
But it's way cleaner now in the
UFC that it's ever been before.
But I think there's also,
I like the fact that one fcs available
for guys who don't want to be clean.
Yeah.
Rises available for guys.
We don't want to be clean.
You know,
there's an argument either way,
there's an argument for the pride way,
which was everybody knew
that everybody was on it.
Hey there,
I tested pride,
right?
We're [inaudible].
Hey boss,
what's this?
Why is this a vial?
Just sitting here?
I mean buddy,
I did it cold or the boss store.
I was going backstage with
the camera showing everybody,
hey man,
what's up?
Hey you,
this is how you look at that.
And it's frighteningly
training and you know what?
Then I say,
okay,
we walk into the room from the doctors.
So I opened the door and I looked at the
side and I see all the pts there would
hold little sticks on them,
right?
And I close the door right
away and I look in the camera,
I said,
give me one moment to the very busy,
let me walk in and ask for permission.
So I walk in and I grab
one of those cups and I,
she green tea,
I fill it up and it put
the same cup next to it.
So then when you weren't even,
you should open it allowed
to that and be that close.
So I'm,
yeah,
she,
I could have got,
can contaminate it,
everything.
So I'm walking in and I'm saying,
oh,
these are the doctors here.
And they looked at us and think,
Oh hey,
the p test.
I said,
man,
wouldn't it be great if you
can taste what fighter it is
and these people,
they looked at me as,
I take my green tea and
I take the thing off.
And they go like,
no,
no.
Can I take a little sip?
And I said,
no.
I go,
it's out a Coleman or
there is a clear illustration.
Yeah,
not water.
And it's all at the end of the day,
a manifestation of probably some
shit you haven't worked out,
which is still a feeling of insecurity.
Still a hole you can't fill.
Oh,
I hope I can move away from that
savage with a Martini in your hand.
The giant hard Dick.
And you've paid 30 Russian hookers to
hang out with you for a month cause your,
your doctor found a blemish on your tumor.
Well that's a different,
some shit going down and it's growing now
it's starting to cut off the supply to
your,
your blood.
Yeah.
You're getting blood clots and
your feet go numb at night.
I wonder what I would do.
Let me think about that cause
so let's just take that.
I got him a hug.
Give me,
so how much time do I have?
Not much.
Uh,
you can wake up every morning.
You,
you set the alarm clock for 5:00 AM
with Creedence Clearwater revival,
bad moon rising.
Your Papa Viagara start
drinking your guts.
Enormous.
It's hitting,
definitely,
definitely have cancer.
You know,
you have cancer.
There's probably some
internal shit going on,
but your dick still gets hard.
And you still got $7
billion to burn through.
Your kids are calling you.
You look at the phone like,
fuck you.
You're not getting any of this.
I started a school,
dude.
Ah,
every day.
Every everyday.
The grilling steaks onboard chef.
I call every girl,
mom and Mama.
Everything is steak.
Steak in the morning.
Who gives a fuck Martinis and stay far?
Yeah.
Martini steak and a fucking
mason jar filled with Viagara
down those fuckers all day.
Can't hear a thing.
Ears are closed up.
Just a big old cray cray.
A
pubic mound.
Yeah.
Your head is constantly aching from
the Viagara flowing through your veins.
Why am I just tick is like fucking hammer.
I guess I just do some fucking,
you've got a giant fat belly
with white hair all over.
Just a big fat white in your Dick.
Smells like cheese.
It takes smells like old chambers.
Why this not going to happen to me?
You and the girls were all have
those shoes with the red bottoms.
You know those shoes are
the Christian Louis towns?
Yeah,
that's the ones.
That's why I get a hard on when I buy
gifts for those girls all have that.
You make them keep those shoes on and
you fucked their mouths where they're
lying on their stomach so that the shoes
are up in the air so you can see the
bottom of the shoes.
What about for you about this?
About this way and then
your heart attacks.
And then when I come I go,
I go,
you're welcome.
And when you die they just throw you
overboard cause he's bitches hate you now.
So like he's dead,
he's finally fucking dead and you
even get to go through the will.
What's in the,
well,
what's it?
What do I get?
Do I get anything?
And then nothing you don't get often
they just drag him by his ankles.
Chuck them over the side.
Wow.
The sharks come and eat them.
They won't eat me.
I'm so full of sin.
So full of sand and just the sharks.
Sharks will eat a shoe.
Well not,
I don't know.
Not My thing to be turned off by your sin.
You've,
you've,
I think so.
Really?
I want to leave behind a very,
a shredded corpse.
Uh,
I want people to go,
that's a,
that's a good looking 90 year old,
right?
Hmm
[inaudible]
yeah.